[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum ryan's here hello how
are you bud i'm all right
yeah yeah the world is a
[ __ ] crazy place and it's hard not to
feel
yep i was watching the news i just saw
this ukrainian woman talking about it
and just her family and having to like
get up and
have to be moved and the fear she had i
just anyway i don't want to get into
it right now but it just uh yeah it's
just like you know [ __ ] love each
other god bless man what is going on man
what is going on
i don't know i don't know either but
welcome welcome to the podcast hopefully
this is an hour where you're just going
to enjoy and not have to deal with
politics and i have to deal with other
stuff and you just hear someone who you
may or may not know hear a good
conversation here an open candid
conversation you might learn something
[Music]
i always try to ask questions that
real people would ask real folks
and
thank you for spending an hour
of your week of your time with us it
means a great deal
if you like the podcast please subscribe
if you're just here for cedric please
subscribe and write a review it really
helps the podcast
and uh if you want to support the
podcast more you can go to patreon.com
inside of you that's p-a-t-r-e-o-n dot
com slash inside of you to give back to
the podcast more i love my lovable
patrons i give them shout outs at the
end of the episode
so there's that
um also our handles if you want to
follow us ryan at inside of you paula on
twitter at insideablepodcast on
instagram and facebook that is correct
yeah yeah you know your stuff ryan i
know a couple of things and not a couple
things that is at the top of the list
good for you i know the social handles
of the podcast uh
guys
this coming weekend
march 5th 2 p.m and 6 p.m i'm playing
music my band's sun spin go to
sunspin.com for tickets or go to
stageit.com for tickets s-t-a-g-e
dot com type in sunspin and we're
playing two shows 2 p.m 6 p.m pacific
standard time i hope you'll enjoy it
people who have never come to the came
come come come to the podcast or to the
concerts came last month and loved it
are gonna return i hope you give it a
chance we play covers we play originals
there's zooms there's prizes it's a good
time so uh 2 p.m at 6 p.m
go to sunspin.com sunspin is the name of
the band uh you can also go to
sunspin.com for merch and if you want
any inside of you merch just go to
inside of you online store there's
tumblers and autograph lex luthor
pictures and
small little scripts and small lunch
boxes and
inside of you swag so there's all that
stuff too
and uh i hope you'll head over there to
the inside of you online store i think
it's 10 off i forgot what the code the
password is there the code what's called
it's called
i don't know you're just gonna have to
figure it out i don't remember it uh but
uh hey this is uh a fun podcast this is
a buddy of mine an old buddy of mine
uh cedric yarbrough and he is
wonderful to talk to this is ryan ryan
loved this episode this is a fun one
this this will if you're in a funk this
will
bring the funk yeah and the good ones
bring the funk out
because there's a funk out only because
there's a ceelo green impression that's
why oh yeah oh he's cedar's so so
talented
and more importantly a lovely human
being who i adore and i appreciate him
coming on the podcast even though he
gave me [ __ ] about why he wasn't on it
earlier
i take it in stride cedric i take it in
stride let's get into
he get he's got reno 911 stuff coming
out too the movie just came out
he's got the series coming out yeah
dorino 911 i mean he's got stuff going
on he's always working let's get inside
of cedric yarbrough it's my point of
view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
you weren't 40 year old virgin yeah
that was a while back do you know what i
do
[ __ ]
i don't i do know what you do i sort of
know you here's the thing man yeah i
don't know we've been friends yeah but
like i think friends a lot of times they
don't get deep they don't get to know
each other
i mean we know each other but we don't
know each other's career like life
talking about each other's
jobs and stuff i don't know if that's
something we do we talk about
movies and talk about like fun [ __ ] and
ed begley ed bagley jr
if we were at a uh
for the listeners we don't want to have
inside actors inside because we don't we
don't do that we share yeah
we were at a uh party carrie fisher's
party like great fishing amazing great
loved her very fisher and i took you you
introduced me yeah
yeah and and ed begley was there and we
just couldn't stop saying bagley ed
begler is it bigly is it begley i think
it's bigly and it's a junior it's a
junior it's a bailly hello i'm ed
or
junior we just i remember that's stupid
i don't even stupid
i think that's just
you and me laughing at it i think so i
don't know if that's funny to anyone
else uh it doesn't matter where i am
laughed i'm enjoying it ryan laughs but
it's well but cedric and i have a sort
of a relationship where you know we're
friends we hang out he came christmas
morning we hung out uh we went to billy
ocean together we saw billy ocean we had
a blast we do a lot of fun things
together had a lot of adventures a lot
of adventures remember that time i
i basically broke up on your halloween
party
what happened do you not remember that
okay so some white dude oh
some random white guy showed up to the
party wearing
uh not black face but definitely
darkened skinned
skin and he
put some makeup on his skin
an afro
a 70s
type shirt that was kind of open
and then chains
on yes
and i looked over and i'm like
what
stuff
wait wait wait wait a minute wait what
what so i had to go up and
so what is hey how are you doing what
what's your costume what is this
uh
i i'm a i'm a 70s guy
70s
guy
really and so i i walked away for a
second
i composed myself and i'm like come on
bruh
this is not i mean he's lying he knows
what he's doing come on man like what is
that and
but ultimately this guy was kicked out
of the party yeah but i
[ __ ] him up a little bit and
kind of messed up your party
you didn't mess up my party that's
exactly what i want to happen at my
party is for you to mess up some [ __ ]
who is wearing something ridiculous like
that that was kind of so stupid and i
don't think people really like i i
didn't look at it because i i first of
all i don't really you know i'm not
you're enjoying yourself yeah i don't
really take the time to look at
something somebody's working like i
don't really and then i go wait a minute
yeah yeah it kind of shocked you because
you don't think you would see anything
like that i don't know what he was doing
i don't know if he was racist was he
racist
yeah okay
i would assume that he's racist like if
i'm jewish and if he came there in
holocaust garb
i might say that i might do the same
thing you might want to know what i
don't know what you said because i i
thought i should
i'm uh whatever
whatever you know and like no that's
you're not a vagabond
no no sir no no no no no no no no no no
it's good you did that though well you
have to stand up [ __ ] [ __ ] people up
sometimes sometimes when's the last time
you were in a fight oh that was a long
time ago i try not to do it i'm almost
50 years old it's kind of embarrassing
now yeah it is but you don't want to get
a fight no you don't i know you don't
either but that was something that you
were like what are you doing this is a
complete smack disrespect
it really was you know it it upset me
only because it took me too much time to
figure it out like i go wait a minute oh
[ __ ] now what is he wearing well because
you don't you can't believe
this is happening yeah you can't believe
this is your life yeah i've i've i've
gone in you know certain confrontations
where it's just your life kind of
flashes but you know is this really
what's happening right now
do i really is someone would be there
for me
yes that can someone really need
somebody to be that silly and that mean
and
is it my time to confront someone with
this
right now yeah
come on man but you know what i'm at a
party i'm at halloween my friends my
boys party we're having a great time and
then this [ __ ] happened but you would
have been more upset with yourself if
you hadn't said something or hadn't done
something like who am i well i've had
that situation like growing up you know
i'm from minneapolis and so
that was you know my family and
and prince were the only black people
this is prince from minneapolis yeah i
didn't know that did you know that ryan
look famously from minneapolis yeah i
should know that thanks for hammering me
with uh
that's all we got louis anderson
prince
he had louie anderson we had him god
bless him we had prince you had prince
we had paul bunyan
didn't need that we had paul bunyan yeah
whole was so there was a lot of racism
in minneapolis did you grow up with a
lot of racism oh yeah so you felt it
constantly
isn't that whack that we gotta we start
in this
this episode this way who started it
me yeah [ __ ] i won't finish it
damn come on but all right we don't have
to get into that but zach levi talk
about race no
no he i don't think any of your other
white superhero friends we've had some
we've had african-american people we've
had asian people i know white people i
know but the white folks never talk
about who they yeah i don't think people
want to hear about racism towards white
people i don't think it happens very
often yeah i mean look it probably does
yeah it does they're the ones being
wearing
the awful outfits
you're a little superhero friend
and i gotta come in and
look man don't do that [ __ ] right now
at this
party you know
listen man change the subject which we
don't have to because i want to get we
can get into it more and you know and to
change the subject again
i'm changing your subject go ahead
i was thinking about your theme song
it's my point of view yeah you're
listening to inside of you do you ever
have
guest
singers
i haven't okay
i was just thinking
uh it's my it's my point of view i'm
already [ __ ] tired of you
with celo [ __ ] green
[Laughter]
maybe
that's pretty good can we i mean i can
stand in for ceelo that is pretty good
or do you karaoke celo songs oh yeah
what's that song the famous song
it's my point of view [ __ ] you
[Laughter]
but i actually know cee lo we we don't
have to get me
let's just get cee lo what did he do
little green
what else is celo doing
you just got silo
i don't think he'd like to hear that no
but i'm just saying he i'm sure he's
doing a lot but
why not
wouldn't that be great this is a big
podcast that's a big opportunity though
for me to get like ceelo to do like the
theme song for at least one episode
it's my point of view
you know who i thought you were doing is
the woman at the lakers game oh cedric
and i went to a lakers game another
inside there's another inside there's
this wonderful woman but i remember
there's this man in front of her trying
to get through the vip into the
chairman's lounge and he goes he looks
at her and goes oh i'm with them
no no
yes yeah and she looks at him and goes i
don't know who you is
we just owe it nowaday we have been
doing that for years
people don't think she's a real person
she is a real person but
yeah it's one of those like
worms that you know those songs that are
in your head all over but that is in my
head ed begley and that i don't know who
you were
she got so pissed off this dude was
wearing this track suit this crazy track
suit i remember but it was like the four
of us
four of us were there yeah but all of us
clocked
i don't know who you with
that thing
so
and we can't tell her about it right no
you can't what are you gonna say no you
can't we always quote you what
that wouldn't work that wouldn't no no
it wouldn't fly off
she might be offended yeah yeah
we can't i don't know
hey listen you've been you're i i always
look at you
like i look at myself in terms of
we're two guys who i think people
probably go i know that guy
i know that dude yeah but they can't
kind of usually they can't what is he
what who is that do you go through that
a lot where people are just kind of
staring at you looking at you pointing
at you yes uh
either they know right away or
that either you know that i went to
school with you or i
how do i know you you owe me money you
owe me money right
no no that's that ain't
no you do
you owe me some money no man that ain't
me
uh i
kind of tying everything together one
time i i got in a
fight over that
what yes man
how are you getting people like crazy
because people are just
i don't know some guy was like hey
you mad tv
wait what
you mad tv ain't you
no that's i i am not
mad tv
see you changed
you changed
uh huh no you from mad tv
i know you
sir i worked on television and film i am
not from i didn't do that
and
some dude
from somewhere hauled off and
and hit me in the face some guy just
came up and hit you yes
because you said you weren't on mad tv
yeah bruh
yeah
was this person white no
it was a black man these were black
these were black fellas
did you fight back
uh
i i couldn't believe it okay
i couldn't believe this was there was
another
my life is flashing in front of me and i
and somebody actually was videotaping it
so
it might you know it might still be
online actually this whole oh i got to
see this no why would you want to see me
get hit no i wouldn't want to see you
get hurt were you hurt no i mean i can
take a punch of being that many but i
got hit
and couldn't believe and the rage within
me
just was like
i think i said i will [ __ ] destroy
you do you know that because i i
couldn't believe
what was happening
and i just like okay i got to remember
where i am and who i am and i don't
want to [ __ ] this guy up just because of
this but it was such a weird cheap shot
uh because of
you know mistaken identity it was just
wow it's just so weird bruh
and you kind of let it go in a way i did
i let it go
i had to breathe and just like
this is ridiculous
what am i why am i fighting this guy
yet it's
i'm humiliated yet
be mature about this calm down oh you
know that's the thing about this whole
with the older you get when you're
younger you can get in a fight and
people like oh he's like in his 20s but
when you're like in your 40s or whatever
yes and you get in a fight it's just
it's just embarrassing also just like
what are you doing right
like
the law lawyer
lawsuits all that stuff is flashing my
mom what she would think yeah all this
stuff is flashing in my head just like
that such so quickly and uh you know i
decided you know i'm not gonna
so you didn't you didn't hit him i did
not hit him i got popped
right but i left it alone you know
this podcast is sponsored by better help
online therapy
everybody knows these guys
everybody loves them i love them ryan
that's great yeah yep it's helping you
getting a lot out of it ain't men
look folks relationships take work
especially the most important one you
can have in your life and that is your
relationship with yourself a lot of us
will drop anything to go help someone we
care about we'll go out of our way to
treat other people well but how often do
we give ourselves the same treatment
it's true we don't we're not good to
ourselves enough
and you got to be good to yourself and
you'll learn how to be good to yourself
but one of those things you could do is
join
better help this month better help
online therapy wants to remind you that
you matter just as much as everyone else
does and therapy is a great way to make
sure you show up for yourself ryan what
would you say better help is doing for
you
uh it is helping me to uh
learn
about myself better uh how to treat
myself better uh
and just talking about things that are
bothering me however big or small yeah
because sometimes you think oh i have
friends to talk to i have
no you you can't be
absolutely open with your thoughts and
your demons and your thing just with
friends or you know people think they
take it it's so
easy you know like oh i don't need to
worry about that and it builds up and it
builds up and investors and
we all implode at some point
so we got to take care of ourselves and
better help online therapy is there to
help us better help is online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy and
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours
give it a try and see why over 2 million
people have used better help online
therapy this podcast is sponsored by
better help and inside of you listeners
get ten percent off their first month at
betterhelp.com
inside that's b e t t e r h e l p dot
com slash
inside thank you better help
couldn't do it without you inside of you
is brought to you by creatures of habit
creatures
with a k folks
let me just tell you right away i had
some of this oatmeal yesterday and it
was absolutely delicious
it was absolutely delicious and it's
exactly what i need to get on to my
healthy stage that you know
transitioning into not eating big candy
bars or not eating things with tons of
salt you know this is something that
i just really appreciate that just helps
me get on my way and gives me energy
creatures of habit is an in-your-face
lifestyle and wellness brand rooted in
delivering nutritional healthy habits
alongside cozy apparel
meat
the protagonist an incredibly delicious
highly optimized superhuman oatmeal
packed with 30 grams of plant-based
protein vitamin d3 omega-3 fatty acids
probiotic and digestive enzymes uh note
this is not just oatmeal the protagonist
is your daily wellness insurance
designed and created for convenience
whether you're running out the door or
like to prep the night before the
protagonist comes in 4 easy to whip up
recipes you just add hot water overnight
in the fridge in the microwave or in a
smoothie and because we want you to
operate at your absolute best in
addition to being plant-based the
protagonist is also gluten-free soy and
dairy-free non-gmo and allergen free
these are all the things that i like
you know i this is what this is why i
could eat this
this is why i enjoy it otherwise i get
myself in a lot of trouble raise your
hands if you want to eliminate stress
and chaos from your morning routines
that guy
we see you and we got you the
protagonist does the trick every time
anywhere and for anyone take it on the
road when you're traveling on a camping
trip in your bag to work or the gym and
start your day with all the energy
living requires hop over to creatures of
habit.com that's creatures with a k
creaturesofhabit.com
and use promo code inside 15 that's
inside 15 to get 15 off your first
purchase
creaturesofhabit.com with a k and use
promo code inside15 for 15 off your
first order remember we are a direct
outcome of our daily habits some habits
will break you some will make you
creatures of habit is here to support
you on the journey of making greatness a
bigger part of your life
let me ask you i don't really know the
answer to this i don't know the answer
to this i know how close you are with
your mom yes but i don't know anything
about growing up cedric growing up where
was his dad because you don't talk about
your dad much i don't know i don't know
that story yeah now how was it growing
up for you
it was a uh religious
uh growing up i grew up grew up without
my father
from the gecko from the get
from the get my father
uh
was
uh without my mom's knowledge at first
she didn't know this that he was already
married already had a whole thing going
on she had a family yeah and she didn't
know how
when she did
then she she uh that was that and so
took me and
and we were off and uh but uh religious
background jehovah's witness background
did you know that i did not know that
yeah now you guys don't celebrate any
holidays we don't celebrate any holidays
or we do you you didn't because you were
you were a jehovah's witness then you're
not you're not now no right no well
well we huh we we celebrated christmas
yeah
do you remember that
you were at my birthday you know yes yes
so i'm with you um but yeah it was a
and it and
being in minneapolis
uh
one black kid in school also a jehovah's
witness
was very alienating you know it was very
um
other
so you weren't popular at all no
no no you didn't fit in no no no no no
no no being black and a job as witness
in in minneapolis and 80s was not
happening it was not conducive to
happiness yeah do you did you uh have to
uh stand
for the uh allegiance
for uh pledge of allegiance yes yes
please allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america yeah right from
the beginning beginning in the morning
at 8 am
i
that's not what our deal was we we
couldn't stand up so you were the colin
kaepernick
is that right yeah of
grade school in minneapolis well he was
standing up for racism i was
sitting down
you know that was already you know
teachers were already like
hating on me and you know like oh
you could at least stand i remember a
teacher telling me
that and would you say i'm just like i'm
only
doing what my mom
asked told me to do wow so
we i was uh jehovah's witness
until i was a teenager
and then you know i was finally like
this does this ain't making sense none
of this is really how did your mom deal
with that she was
kind of okay about it
um not happy but
she you know what else are you gonna do
like as a teenager you know i'm already
kind of
thinking and
coming up with things and you know
uh you know i got my own mind so uh yeah
uh so
cut to
now
well actually several years ago my my
mom isn't a jehovah's witness now she
finally got out of it got out of it what
got her out of it the internet
what on the internet she finally
discovered the internet
we got her a computer and she read about
it and she was
looking up things and checking out
things for herself and getting on
youtube and
oh
wait why oh
35 years later it makes
sense
you know so
um
yeah uh
crazy did your dad ever come back into
the picture did he ever try to come back
in the picture no no and um i don't know
if he knows what i do um i don't know if
that side of the family
knows what i do you don't know anybody
over there i don't i don't is that was
that kind of hard on you to be like you
know hey i have this whole family here
why can't i see them
i i guess it was as a kid it was
something i didn't really think about
um
[Music]
my mom was all we had it was way enough
you know i felt like
extremely loved she was she was loving
she was supportive all that she's
fantastic she's always been always been
always been always been god made me
weird
you know woke me up
in two in the morning
with a
bowl of macaroni and cheese and
and let's turn on seven brides for seven
brothers you know at three in the
morning yeah you know
that kind of stuff that sounds like my
grandmother my grandmother always like i
hear the slippers on the floor
mikey
and it's like tune them when i go you
want a cheese sandwich
okay
and you do it right but that's how they
showed love you know that they care and
love love for you with food and with
entertainment and with things that they
enjoy and you see how much she is
enjoying it you know and i
you know
i know that's exactly why i do what i do
you know right is
still pleasing her and still
trying to entertain her is she a happy
person she's ecstatic ecstatic i just
really i i uh
got in an amazing position you know in
my career that i'm able to buy my mama
home
and i just purchased her a house
wow yeah so
uh a couple months ago what was her
reaction
how did it happen how did it go down
like did you call her and say or was it
in person what was it that happened so
my brother
uh i'm the oldest of four
my youngest brother was the eyes in
minneapolis and so i was able to call
him
i go uh he he had just purchased a home
with his wife
got his realtor
and we were able to you know while i'm
here in l.a
but uh you know find a home for her and
uh did she know this she didn't know
anything so the house was already
purchased like you didn't give her a
choice like this is where you're living
yes
yes but i asked her you know uh
after you know
with months of asking different
questions about you know if you were
ever to you know
live anywhere you know what what would
you like would you like a like you know
a a two-level home or you know you know
my knees are you know not what they used
to be so you know
you know like that so she would i was
you know getting you're getting
information okay so family style house
what is it the
one story one-story home
you know two-car garage
um but she's yeah we surprised her on
halloween uh this this past year and uh
and filmed it and she cries she's crying
she's the best person to surprise
because she she's just
just all heart you know
is that's great well you know the
difference between my mother and your
mother
yeah
i would think is that it sounds like
your mother doesn't really ask you for
money doesn't ask you for things is very
appreciative doesn't isn't manipulative
am i correct in saying that yes yeah
very different she's
a school bus driver for special needs
kids
all heart
just the sweetest lady wow funny funny
funny you know
everyone loves her so i
i very fortunate to have someone like
that you know yeah so
you know uh and that the fact that she's
still here and
she's only 60. 60 60 68 yeah that's
young i know god yeah lesser god closer
so
she uh
you know we had to hook her up make sure
she's she's good and now because when i
went home i always had to stay in a
uh hotel and now stay at mom's house
got the hub now is it a two-bedroom
two-bedroom home
and gonna you know now everyone gets to
go home
for holidays yes you know yeah for
anything and you do that you celebrate
as a family i think we're going to this
this will be you know this will be the
first this year in the year of our of
our first of everyone being able to does
that make you feel good i feel that's
great it feels
amazing it the people that support you
and you're able to help them you know
there's nothing like it my mother yeah i
remember when i first started getting
some success
she called me do you remember the
basketball player caliber chaney
calrup cheney played for iu and i grew
up in indiana so i knew albert cheney's
name
and my mother because he played for the
washington bullet she goes you know
caliber chaney's bought his mother a big
house in evansville
that's my mom
[Laughter]
damn oh yeah what was this after
smallville or was this during the
beginning of small buildings okay the
very beginning this was i don't think
this was small but this might have been
before but you know i mean yeah always
always hand out hands out you know
always like you know always i don't you
don't have any i just don't i don't i go
mom i bought you a house you pay for
your property taxes you don't have any
all you have is your car and your and
your food and you have a husband who has
a job who does
why are you why are you constantly broke
and why are you asking me why are you
always asking me well you're the only
one that has any money
but that's i've been dealing with that
my whole life i've been dealing with
that my whole life that's that's
tough it's tough on you because it's
like you want like my grandmother never
asked me for anything and i just want to
give her whatever she wants right you
always want to give to the people who
don't ask you yes i'm buying you this
new chair i want to buy you a new tv i
want to take you to dinner no you're not
buying me anything yes that's who you
want to give to yeah but my mother like
welcomes it and i love my mother but
she's it's been difficult over the years
because now it's kind of you slowly
resent
constantly giving things giving money
giving them
so it is tough so i
envy you the fact that you have a mother
who just wants
her happiness is you being happy it
really is and it's never been pressure
um well all my family you know my my
siblings are that way no one's ever
asking me for anything you know other
than
you know um
you know an occasional hello you know
that
we're all really self-sufficient
um nobody asks you for anything no
no isn't that a treat it is but it also
is a little
sometimes
i wish you guys were a little more
involved
in this you know in what in this
because
i'm the only one here
in l.a i'm the only one
right so it sometimes it i mean a lot of
it is lonely
are you lonely uh not
i'm alone and every once in a while
lonely because
everyone's still in minneapolis
everyone's there you know right
so you hear about like people and
their families getting in their
this business and helping them whether
it be a stand-in whether they're an
assistant whether they're you know
whatever so
they have their own careers they have
their own families they got all a lot of
stuff going on i'm not begrudging them
that but
it would you know be
wow great to have somebody out yeah to
be someone to be out here actually
uh you know doing this hustle with me
which would be cool yeah uh being
self-reliant and uh
and your own
self-made man is
is
an amazing thing we didn't come from
anything you know yes so um
it's just you know you want to
whether it be
family or you know you and i are both
single having someone
with you to see some of this [ __ ] that
goes down
uh you know be why are we single cool do
you have an answer for it
how old are you i'm 48 and i'll be 49
soon yes and i'll be 50 soon yeah and i
sit there and i wonder and my friends
are like because you just you're
expecting perfection you're expecting
this you're expecting this you just
gotta just go with it go for something
accept flaws i do accept flaws but i
think i deal with you know remembering
all the dysfunction and all this and i
don't want to get married i don't want
to say maybe i do
but uh i i don't know i don't know the
answer i don't have the answer do you
ever feel like
man am i gonna be alone for the rest of
my life i've started to this past
christmas was like wait
i'm going to rosen bombs chris this
morning yeah
i got to go to michael's wait
i haven't got nobody
got no lady needed to see he doesn't
what's the matter with us wait a minute
damn
but listen you know this shit's hard man
relationships
they're hard they are difficult and i
never
like when i think about as a kid i never
thought
being in a relationship was going to be
hard dating and all that stuff i thought
it was going to be easy but it isn't and
and especially when you
you know you you
you figure out some of the building
blocks of what a good relationship works
or how it works
some of that stuff isn't here
you know not all the time it's it you
know finding someone who's also done a
lot of work on themselves as much as
you're trying to do yeah
that's hard sometimes yeah and i
definitely wanted to make sure
that i wanted to
come out here and do what i wanted
what i came out here for i didn't come
out here for a relationship right away
right i wanted to you know do something
with my life
i want to
let's go let's go let's get this i want
to have success yes i was eating mac and
cheese and getting woke up
two in the morning but it's for nothing
you know
let's get let's you know i've been
watching seven brides and the sound of
music
and learning all these steps but you
have just to get in a relationship but
you have relationship you know
but you've had success now i mean yeah
reno 911 the goldbergs bernie mac arrest
development speechless bojack horseman
the list goes on you've had success you
made money you bought your mom a house
so what now so
i brought a ring
you're going to propose right now yeah
michael
do you think you'll ever get married
you and me and egg bagley junior
uh
i don't know it may be it it's it's
possible you know i'm
that's another thing
i've
learned about
life and
living out here and
work
is that i've i've adjusted my my dream
because a lot of the dreams have come
true
um
you know working i just wanted to be a
working actor yeah
that's that's happened that and and i've
been able to do a lot with that and so
now i'm adjusting the dream more you
know do i want to get into directing do
i want to get in to producing do i want
to
be you know someone's husband
do you know those kinds of things are
now
you know i'm starting to really shape
that because i want to
i i want to be a an individual that's a
little more whole and not
so broken you know i i feel like a lot
of people get in these these
relationships and they haven't doesn't
work
yeah you need somebody to help fix or
fulfill that something that you're
missing yeah and that's not that's not
why you do it no it's not
it's
i think you want to
you can't be perfect
but you can do
some of the work you know yeah and and
fix your fico score and
you know
get insurance
don't
get someone in here is that what it's
called the fico score
the credit the credit score yeah yeah
you know
fix your credit
don't get a girlfriend so you can get on
her dental plan you know yeah that kind
of
kind of stuff where i feel like i've
been in
you know
i've dated in some situations where that
is i'm like
you just
you're not trying to get a free meal
right now
hey you know
well that and that's what this town
sometimes is sometimes it is a little
scavenger-y and sometimes people are too
self-sufficient it's too the two like
you're now you're with someone who's
just too strong for you i'm like i still
you want you to be a you know i still
want to be able to cuddle you and yeah
take care of you a little bit no she's
like get off me
my own job oh damn okay well
i don't know who you were i don't know
who you're with what but i was trying to
love on you lady
i don't know who you were
inside of you is brought to you by
patreon
whoa in no small part thanks to our
lovely supporters over on patreon
folks if you enjoyed the podcast
you love talking episodes you want to
stay involved with the inside of you
community i highly suggest you check out
what we're doing over on patreon it's
quickly turned into one of the coolest
things i've been a part of over the last
year
so if you want to get early access to
episode content check out the patreon if
you want to interact with other fans of
the show check out the patreon if you
want to get exclusive access to have
your questions asked during the show
ryan
check out the patreon check out the
patreon
uh heck if you just love what we do and
want to keep this train all rolling
check out the patreon
doesn't take much to get involved and
i'm there all the time chatting with
folks and putting together live hangouts
i literally would not be able to do this
without you folks so thank you patrons i
literally would not be able to do this
without you folks so thank you
to get more involved in the community
today head over to patreon.com inside of
you that's patreon.com
inside of you
i will see you all there
hey let me ask you this because i've
seen you do so much improv and it's just
like you know we get into that what
what do you think makes a great impr
improviser what makes a great improviser
does it take
can anyone do it can anyone start out
and just take the classes and work your
way up to be this somebody who can
improv proposate
improvise
improvise
improvisate yeah no improvise like you
know because you have worked at it you
have
is this something you really have to
take years and years to work on
um
[Music]
your first question can everyone
improvisate improv improvise
everyone can improvise you know that's
what we're doing now right exactly
hopefully you know everyone have a
conversation
um
yes and that's that's what improvisation
is is is having uh a conversation a real
conversation hopefully right and you're
able to you know with the truth of the
situation
it becomes funny right you know
uh
now can everyone be funny
and and do this hey now we're getting
somewhere
yeah no you've been around a lot of that
you just can't
a lot of classes a lot of yes
yes well
my background
is is a theater background you know i i
come from you know
lots of classical theater lots of drama
you know that's what i was i wanted to
be
but
your boy's just [ __ ] funny you know
i'm just
it's just an eight
it makes it impossible
yeah
the number eight uh so uh so i i
i couldn't think of it i couldn't think
of improvising professionally
i like you guys just you know sue me for
you know i never i never said i was the
most articulate person in the world come
on no you're good anyway go ahead it's
good and so i uh
wanted to bring more to scripts
uh to auditions and so i started taking
improv classes and so that's how my my
thing
kind of got
started i i was um
you know i was a uh a vessel
being filled as opposed to
bring
bringing things to my my point of view
to to scripts right being able to have
my personality my spin on it and so
improv helped me with that
so
uh
yes people can hone their skills and i
think a lot of people should most people
should take especially an actor you
should do that yeah yeah but
i i think it's important to yeah to get
out of your skin to get it you know out
of your comfort zone and be able to just
commit being the moment
yes in the moment commit not
you know take that shell and whatever
that is that gloss that whatever that
that
that's impeding you your progress taking
that off and being able to just to open
up and and do things it's scary it's
extremely very scary to open up and just
go whatever comes out of your mouth and
kind of just listen and try to make
something out of nothing i get nervous
every show every show every show like
you feel like i can't do this
not that i can't do this but i'm not
going to do this well
yeah i'm not going to do this well um
you know what after a while you've
you've built up a
i don't know you've built up a
superpower and so
people are coming to see you now
so
this is
might be the last time they ever see you
or you know
live you know have you bombed before
yeah i mean like really just been not
like i'm like oh i'm not
i'm not good tonight i'm
seriously not good yeah no that's never
happened really yeah you've never been
like damn i was off
maybe in a scene but
yeah i was yeah in the scene but then i
turned it up you know
you just i don't know you just curry you
know
you you're confident like yeah okay i
missed that one steph curry but give me
the ball all right all right
oh i'm gonna hit these threes it's gonna
take a second right you know if i still
remember who i am right i'm still dope
still good still me it's still
cedric you know well what would you
rather do if you had a choice i mean
scripted
or improvised improvisate
improvisate or script i i enjoy
scripts i really do i do
i love the written word i do
some people love
you know if they didn't have a script
you know and not
have to memorize you know
for the rest of their life then that
that would be great but not not me i i
like i like scripts i like i love
writers i i've tried to write myself and
you know so i i enjoy that
but
you know i've built up this other thing
and so
i'm able to help writers with
with something
if they need it right but like larry
david and you work with larry david on
curve of your enthusiasm yes
you supposedly get a piece of paper that
says this is where we want the scene to
go yes
go for it yeah go improvise
is that
is that difficult
no or you like that because it's like
okay i know where i'm going it's easier
it's easier definitely easier than what
then on reno when we don't have any kind
of paper they're just like this is a
scene right here this is
could you just go do it uh that's a
whole new guy yeah uh gary anthony
williams he's gonna be uh masturbating
on an escalator
[Music]
go you know that's it that's it
and that's is it scary no that's that
now that's fun
doing a live show
scary
but theater but scary
somebody gives you this is what the
scene is easy you like it it's on film
were you star struck with working with
larry david
no
not at all no
uh
no have you been star struck working
with certain people bernie mac
yes bernie
i was star struck you were i was star
struck with bernie because
i couldn't believe how
generous he was
he was so
sweet to me
so nice
no one nicer man
what do you remember
oh [ __ ] come on you funny
[ __ ]
go ahead go ahead bro do do whatever you
want to do go ahead you know this is the
bernie mac show
please
whatever you do is going to make the
show funny
please
do go ahead bruh he was so
cool with me i felt bernie mac was here
for a second well i really did danger
yeah
i'm scared of you [ __ ]
he was so and now i was like if i ever
get to be number one on the call sheet
that's who i want to be because he's
it's the bernie mac show so i whatever i
do i'm a guest star i'm building that's
what he was saying you you're helping me
my show
so please go go
be as funny as you possibly can and that
was
so eye-opening for me wow that was so
that isn't you don't always see that
with lead actors i have worked with lead
actors i know you have
you don't want to mention any by name
but you've worked with some people that
you were like yeah i'm not that's not a
role model right that's not who i want
to be no
bernie
cedric the entertainer they're they're
like uh they come from those schools of
oh i'm gonna get my i'm gonna get my
shots up you know
go ahead yeah please
get in here scotty pippin and you know
knox them out too please help me yeah
help me win this championship i'm i got
it you know i but
whatever you can bring
is is really beneficial and
you know those are the that's the type
of dude i want to be you know
and i've always been you know please uh
bring whatever you can here right
but you just wanted to impress him you
wanted to make him laugh
yeah
and i had a point of view you know from
my improv and you know theater training
and i felt like the character should be
this
and
you know i just trusted my instincts but
having someone like that say yeah go
was all i needed you know sometimes you
need someone to say yes
yes you know
someone you just need that like yeah
dude yeah that well we all need to do it
yeah we all need that whatever it is
like hey this is this is great let's get
going let's go with this but that's why
i also like improv because it is that
you know even
even reno reno is that reno91 is that
but not it's funny because uh you know
when you're a cop you you're stopping
everyone from doing [ __ ] right don't no
no right take that out of your mouth sir
don't right get out of that tree
but it's always
get that out of your hand sir no no no
but it's it's great to you know talk to
actors who come and play with us because
it's
like
we're just the k we're we're just trying
to keep you in bounds but please do
whatever you want to do you know yes yes
yes yes go as far as you can yeah have
you ever dealt with anxiety depression
any of those things in your life
not
really uh although
recently
i got into
meth
methamphetamine no you didn't god forbid
here on i got on that heroin
uh
the internet is
the internet has some [ __ ] man they say
some crazy [ __ ]
and we were talking about just before we
got in here wait we talked about you
know you're like oh you look like you
lost me and i'm trying
i i packed on some
packed on some pounds
and i
you know
when
just
i mean
not just the holidays over some years
i've i've gotten bigger
you know in weight
and
i didn't really realize you know i'm oh
damn i'm i'm up to three bills here
right now really so yeah
yeah i got i was over 300 pounds
but you don't really look at you and
think that
that's what people say and because of my
height and you know i'm able to carry
care of yourself yeah yes you know
deeper voice
the brother part
the big old dick part you know all that
carrying all the weight there
so okay so the thing
was i uh
yeah that was
you know
i i was carrying
like
success and and happy weight it wasn't
depression
it was like ah i could finally eat
i can eat
wherever i want pizza
i almost turned into cosby right you did
yeah you would have done it if cosby
wasn't such a
man i'm gonna do it anyway do it berlin
and then the hoagie came and the
chocolate cake and then
and all the things
came in my mouth and then and then they
ate them
you see
and then rudy came and then she was
eating whispering and then we were
okay all right
it's he's that's still stupid funny i
don't know i know it's
you know i just have to forget about all
the [ __ ] now and just go remember the
old cosby remember that when that was
just
but but go ahead anyway but you yeah so
it was i mean i was
drinking and having a good enjoying life
yeah so what's well it's
not the sexiest thing
even though i'm a comedic actor
it's not always viable in hollywood well
what do you want to do what do you what
do you want to weigh what do you want to
look like well
my
ex
representation was like
you know
uh you're fat
he said that or she said that they said
that
right to your face not
on the phone they said you're fat yeah
and what'd you say
um oh well you're fired and we won't be
worried you said that yeah right away
uh yeah well i it i was
getting rid of them
and that's when they
retaliated in a way yeah and go oh
you're gonna get rid of us uh-huh well
the reason why you've been working is
because
you that now i'm gonna have to shoot you
in your pinky toe
sorry that's a pink guitar that's a
random that's a harlem night's quote
um but so they said the word fat to you
on the phone because i usually hear this
usually it's with women unfortunately
where they're like talking about your
weight talking about this with men you
know men don't you know
and then boom they laid it on you yeah
and that hurt
uh yeah
that landed
but you know how easy some of it is
because some of it's true
you know i have to think about
what they're seeing
what
hollywood is is saying to them
i have also have to and what
some of these internet folks are saying
you know so some of it is you know i
have to internet people talk about
you're overweight my appearance yeah
yeah
like what
uh
oh
that deputy jones is
sure eating them donuts
and you don't like reading that
uh no no i don't i don't like reading it
but it's you know the internet's so
funny because it's
it's mixed
because it's huge because humans
we our thing is that we talk about each
other we you know we gossip
we talk about each other behind our
backs
but now the internet is you know talking
behind your back in front of you and
tagging your name
in it
and on a computer where i'll never be
able to get to you right you know
so
so the combination of that
maybe i need to
stop some of this oh i am over 300
pounds
you know and you have to realize
uh yes i do comedy but
i don't want people worried about about
me when they're watching like oh i hope
is you know i never once thought that
well i'm worried about him not to say
that you shouldn't lose weight for your
own yes reasons and for you wanting to
be healthier and whatever because by the
way this may sound stupid but
i recently
was up to 194. it doesn't sound like
much i've always been a thin guy yeah
but
i looked up and from my weight and
height i was overweight
i was overweight
just and you're like how am i overweight
yeah
so
it just
perspective yes and you know it's what
you want ultimately that's what you want
it's like hey do i want to be 240 do i
want to be 240 i'm a tall guy i could
live with that that's healthier this is
what i want to do for me and there are
plenty of actors that actually are yes
you know
that's what this is you're supposed to
represent all kinds of folks you know
that because we all comes in we all come
in different kinds of shapes and sizes
but if it's to my detriment of my health
or you know also my money and working
you know i
i have to
internalize that think about it and it
wasn't depressing but it was definitely
something eye-opening for me that i
needed to go okay maybe i need to check
myself on this thing you know maybe you
shouldn't be that happy right maybe you
need to
hang on a second yeah so that made you a
little depressed we're talking about the
depression you had a little situation it
made me sad it made me sad that people
would be that mean
would
talk [ __ ] like that to me my my reps of
all people that people that i'm supposed
to be you know that are supposed to
support you love you hear me take care
of you you know
thought that
and um
but
you know it's
life man
you were a uh i love this
a janitor in college to make money to
pay for your books and [ __ ] yeah a
janitor yeah so when i hear the word
janitor i think of you know someone
mopping and sweeping and cleaning
bathrooms and toilets and dealing with
kids [ __ ]
you were doing that while you were a
student
uh
i wasn't dealing with
uh
kids or anything like that this was
during uh um
my community college days well still the
young people yes yeah well this was
always after hours so
you know i go to school there
and then you know part of me being able
to go to school there was also my my
janitorial
duty how much did you get paid to be a
janitor at the school
um
not very much at all but it was it was
mostly being able to you know pay for
books and did you [ __ ] around were you
goofing around and not really doing your
job or were you good at what oh good oh
no i cleaned they liked you
yeah
yeah getting gum and [ __ ] any weird [ __ ]
that happened after hours that you could
write something about like a little
movie about a guy who's a janitor
i mean i could make some stuff up but
but nothing really happened oh no you
know what i did
figure out the
pythagorean theorem oh really yeah
pythagorean yeah i got up all up on uh
you know
[Laughter]
hypotenuse you got one of the glasses
yeah
triangles in my brain
oh i had a beautiful mind you know what
that's what i need to
do you want to write that with me come
on
me you and ed begley me you and ed
begley bigly hey you know i know you
probably can't talk about this but it's
all over the news zach levi no no not
zach levi he texts me right before the
show and he's like
is you having zach levi on after me for
his fifth time i'm like no
this should be called the about damn
time show episode
because i mean well i wanted you on the
podcast no you did not i want to join
the company how many episodes
have you done
uh
200
but let me tell you something
i wish it was it's timing out it's
timing i understand that and it's not
that i don't love you i don't want you
to be on the show i don't you know i i
wanted you to we've talked about it
overstand
you all your stance but joe latruglio
how i mean how many times he was he was
he was on twice
oh you'll probably be on twice what the
hell's wrong with you
just sam
at bigley
well you're on the damn show hey listen
jeff garland
oh yeah
so
he walked off the set
that's what the news said right ryan
that's yeah that's what i saw what was
it on
i don't know but you saw it on the news
it was a story but he made it around he
walked off the set is he no longer on
the show anymore i don't think the
show's on anymore but i think that was
part of it
uh are y'all talking or yeah
you won't talk to me yes the show is
still on right uh in fact um
the show uh the goldbergs we're talking
about goldbergs is uh
still uh
very much on on television in fact it
got uh it was it had 18 episodes this
season
and uh got picked up for a full 22. so
the show's doing quite well
jeff is no longer on the show
um but
you know
some [ __ ] went down
he was in and he's he's talked about
this you know he was in vanity fair
talking about
his some of his um
i don't know he had he he had
spoken to
the hr department
several times for you know several years
about what was going on
and there were problems on set and
he didn't feel that way so
he didn't feel what way he didn't feel
that
uh he was what he was that what he was
doing was a problem
the it was part of his apparently his
process
did you witness some [ __ ] that you were
like
i uh
i
you know this is it's difficult to say
because
you know i'm
you know i'm a i'm a hired gun i don't
i'm not a serious regular on the show
right i
they they got me to come in and and do
some comedy and then and then i leave
right so
their internal stuff is
is there but you witness some [ __ ] and
here's the good thing he's not on the
show anymore because he so he can't get
you fired
no he can't get me fired but
i i i you know it's it's it's a
difficult thing to do it talk about
other people's
[ __ ] the other people's things you know
right well richard kind he's on the
richard kind he's such the nicest guy in
the world i you know i i love him
and i also love tuna fish
if you guys know richard kind looked him
up yeah look at him bing-bong so he you
know he always
has you know him and jeff were you know
they're pals they are pal they're very
good friends they're they're compadres
and they come from second city
and
he uh
i don't know why i'm i don't know
yelling i mean but that's what but he
sounds exactly like that richard that's
right 100 percent and i i don't i don't
i don't know richard i'm thinking i'm
i'm only saying that so you don't ask me
anymore jeff garland questions really
you don't want to talk about jeff
garland because i i
what can i say you know you could say
god he was the biggest [ __ ] on set
ever i i could say that but you don't
want to but i don't want to say that
because he wasn't the biggest [ __ ] on
on set you say he's one of the biggest
[ __ ] i've had on set
i could say that too
i'm not i'm not going to say that
because
the the thing is you know you like how i
just knock you down with that yeah
and this is why all right all right
george clooney we're best friends
he is
i wonder if george clooney gave him a
million dollars he did he gave he gave
kind of a million dollars yeah he was
one of those guys he was one of those
guys who got a million dollars clooney
apparently gave a million dollars to all
his best friends like 10 people gave him
a million dollars each because he just
you know is their best friends for a
long time but he also put richard
through a lot of [ __ ] i'm sure he did
man some of the stuff that you know
because george does a lot of pranks
apparently but a lot of crazy pranks
like
thank god you became george clooney
because you got in trouble
if cedric yarborough did some of that
[ __ ] hmm no good no richard kind would
be want to fight me
hey this is called [ __ ] talking with
with cedric
these are fast rapid fire questions from
my patrons if you want to join patreon
go to patreon.com inside of you these
are people who really give back to the
podcast this is how we always finish the
podcast but here we go lisa h loved you
on speechless as a special needs mom i
totally identified with maya and
absolutely adored his portrayal of
kenneth
what
she says maya is that right
right what was it like those were many
many drivers characters many drivers
what was it like working on a show that
helped normalize disabilities that it
was um one of the best things i've been
able to do
really
yeah it was
an amazing experience
uh i got to meet so many
parents
of special needs kids
uh that were so thankful to finally have
be represented on tv
and that's what you know most people
want they want to see themselves
on television or in film
let me see my experience you know yeah
you said you had a kid with cerebral
palsy came up to you and says i want to
do that now yeah i want to be an actor
he wants he wants to act now i love that
you know and that
kind of stuff is just like oh my god
that
it feels so good and it just
um
yeah so it was one of the best
experiences i've gotten to to do
uh i loved working you know on on set it
was it was a
long
tedious
but fun experience you know to to do
that but it was great uh leanne what was
it like to work with jeff garland on the
no i'm kidding that wasn't the question
uh she's just like what was it like to
work in the goldbergs did you like enjoy
that though you still enjoy it i still
enjoy it i still love it it's uh
a fun show
uh when i got when i booked the show i
was like does anyone have a jerry girl
on this show and they're like
no i said can i get one
they're like yeah
it's a dream come true because in the
80s i wanted a jerry craw
but mom was like
you can either eat
or you can
get a jerry craw
and i was like i was like yeah let's get
a jared cross she's like idiot
you're going to eat
that [ __ ] costs money to products you
know so
little lisa what do you enjoy more
acting or voice acting
i like all of it lisa man i like being
employed is is fun we get to do some
really
great things and you've done some you
know animation yeah some cool stuff it's
really it's really fun i love
doing uh you know cartoons i've done you
know boondocks and bojack horsemen and
all that stuff and
being able to that's all that
stuff that i learned when i was a kid
your saturday cartoon hooking up words
and phrases and clauses
you know that you remember him jack
sheldon
that was a white man
that jack sheldon the trumpet playing
jazz guy who did all kinds of cocaine
[Music]
in the 80s he was white yes but that
that's a that's a very brother-sounding
voice yeah but that as a child
finding out that that's a white guy made
me go oh my god that i can
i can do all kinds of stuff if that guy
that dude that's just all kinds of l
made me just feel like
oh my god i love animation because you
can do all kinds of stuff yeah you can
be anything uh raj is there a specific
person or experience that taught you
what you didn't want to be as a career
actor or comedian besides jeff garland
no he didn't say
yes i have seen
lots of examples of what i don't want to
be
uh mini
and i just say minnie
and
um and that's you know you learn as much
from
you know the negative as a positive
what your career is what you say no to
it just shapes as much as your career as
what you say yes to
uh so
you know you you learn from you know
people that are some [ __ ]
and you learn from people that are are
mentioned right
a million percent yeah you really do you
learn from the people i don't want to be
like that no i don't want to be because
that's too hard you're coming on set
with that attitude every day that how
that's exhausting exhausting it's got to
be killing you
it has to kill him with kindness and and
yeah being happy being kind is a lot
easier as well i pride myself
on i want to be not difficult but i want
to bring something to this project i
want to i want everyone around me to
have a good time
because i'm having a damn good time but
i also want
you know whatever project i'm doing i've
always made sure that
um
whatever i'm doing i'm making sure that
uh
i do the best that i can and the
audience
if they see me they go okay i don't know
if i like this project but i know i'm
gonna like him right now i know so you
should step up i know cedar's gonna
bring it this is gonna be fun yeah yeah
well look man you always bring it you
brought it today and i hope you come
back again
maybe i gave you [ __ ] but no no i
deserved a little [ __ ] here's another
thing i have a lot of friends who said
that to me like why am i not on the
podcast blah blah why haven't i been in
the podcast by the way i did the same
thing the dax i called dax and go why
haven't i been i guess where you were i
go no i was on your live show i wasn't
even on your regular show you haven't
even had me and i get it because i don't
have a as big of a following i'm not on
a hit show yeah i'm not i i did the same
i was the same i said that to him right
and you could do the same for me my my
imaginary snuffle up against joe
that i do in my closet with that big
layer snuffle up together yeah okay do
you say snuffle love snuff
snuffle up against i say snuffle up i
guess you're wrong it's snappalupicus
yes did you know that ryan no
you you are you enough as well it's
snuff with snuffle
snuffleupagus
he says
again
snuffle up snuffle up i guess
it's not falafel i said snuffalophagus
you sure did
uh cedric it's been a pleasure love you
too thank you for allowing me to be
inside of you today this has been a real
truth
i'm a really good and tired of you
we're michael rosen
but i'm gonna get ceelo could you really
know him
i've met him okay so you couldn't get
him to do the thing you know i can't get
i don't get no silo greetings
yeah i'm always alive
you still got a lot of good stories i
gotta have you back because this is fun
i can't believe it's like time to go i
dude we didn't even get really we got we
were saying we got inside my navel but
we can get
all up inside well we were over here for
an hour if you had gotten here earlier
we would have been here longer oh god i
got all kinds of jeff garland stories
why don't you tell us man
i love you thank you for coming on i
love you too but
uh always interesting always funny and i
love having cedric on the podcast i'm
great i'm glad he just he adds a certain
energy
a certain element quality to it i like
having him on he was he was a lot of fun
it was a lot of fun it was a lot of fun
so thank you for listening if again if
you like the podcast please write a
review please subscribe on youtube apple
spotify stitcher it's everywhere write a
review the handles as ryan said are
inside of you bought on twitter inside
of your podcast instagram and facebook
that's right and if you want to hit the
inside you online store go and get great
stuff there's so much good stuff there
uh also thesunspin.com my band you could
come to our concert this saturday march
5th 2 p.m and 6 p.m two shows pacific
standard time get tickets at sunspin.com
or type in sunspin when you go to
stageit.com that's
s-t-a-g-e-i-t dot com stage dot com type
in sun spin
prizes zooms
music uh it's a lot of fun and each
concert is only 50 minutes 45 minutes so
you're gonna have fun and i see your
messages as they come up and i go oh
look it's a ralph 275 or tab of the 273
you know and i go oh what's going on and
you know i'll i'll give you shout outs
and all that stuff for sure is it not
tabitha 272 though oh yeah tablet the
272. insane not to be confused you see
with two but it was confused but
it was completely confused what's
happening just now 73. it was
it was uh thank you for all your support
um
guys it means the world to me thanks for
uh
you know
let's let's do it let's do this is
patreon.com inside if you want to join
patreon these are the top patrons who
get their name shout out it's part of
one of the tiers if you go to
patreon.com inside of you and become a
patron it's like a big community a big
family and i look forward to you i'll
write a message to you right after you
join within the next few days if you
write them if you
join i i say hey scott tabitha 273
jesus here are the uh
the shout outs
nancy d leah s sarah v little lisa
yukiko jill e brian h nico p robert b
jason w kristen k amelia o allison l raj
c joshua cjp jennifer n stacy l gen s
jamal f janelle b roger s kimberly
e correct mike e l don suprema 99 more
ramirez santiago m chad w leanne p
janine r maya p matty s belinda and
chris h dave h spider-man chase sheila g
brad d
ray h tabitha t tom n liliana a
michelle k taga m betsy
r no
betsy d correct
betsy i'm sorry you should have known
that chad l rochelle marion meg k trav l
dan and big stevie w angel m rhiannon
c correct corey k super sam coleman g
dev
nixon michelle a jeremy c cody r
gavinator david c john b brandy
l no d damn yvore camille s the c the c
joey m willie f christina e adelaide n
omar i alina n eugene and leah chris p
corey patricia heather l jake b james b
james b
bobbitt eddie
[Music]
joshua b tony g sean r megan t mel s
orlando c annie john b caroline r darren
b rob e i thank you guys all for being
top patrons for giving to the podcast
helping us uh
you know trek along is that the right i
think it's truck truck along well that
doesn't sound right
trucking keep on trucking along trucking
along or you just keep on trucking oh
that's that's the thing yeah
that's the ticket i guess yeah i can't
think all the time uh i love you having
you here ryan it's nice to be here don't
know what i do without you you're an
awesome dude um and i think people
really like like ryan i think you know i
see messages all the time saying i love
ryan i love watching michael and ryan
they do they love you
i sent you a message i've seen many i'll
send you i'll start sending them you
your way that's nice i appreciate it
yeah people dig ryan
tell us how much you dig ryan on this
podcast i want to see him on youtube so
i can send him to ryan
um
what else
that's that's about it that's about it
that's about it i would say thank you
for allowing me to be inside of each and
every one of you taking your time to
listen to the podcast there's so many
podcasts out there we know and you
choose us as one of them to listen to so
write a review
thank you
keep rocking in the free world from my
house in the hollywood hills of
california i'm michael rosenbaum i'm
ryan taylor yeah it was a little way by
up there and you guys take it easy uh be
good to yourselves all right be good to
yourselves we'll see you next week
[Music]